this is extremely hard I'm God yet the
Lord a master soccer player actually
never played soccer today i'ma try to
learn how to juggle a soccer ball
20 times this is gonna be super hard I
won't be honest I'm not gonna lie to
myself but you know what I'm gonna do my
best if I'm a better get this imagine
what you could do with your life Sonny
I'm saying all this then I'm gonna suck
okay all right that did not work as I
just learned and figure it out this is
gonna take all day these guys go no you
know what this I have one sighs god damn
I should've wore shorts there's my pants
my pants a little tight one I got this
watch
[Music]
no sufen it bounced up
I got hit it long enough took a bow up I
have to hear a little bit more force oh
oh
test counts that's 300 it's for one -
what about bouncing off the wall is that
possible
what - no that's a bad idea
1 2 3 1 2 3 4 son - wait if I hit it
more in the bottom to come more my way
you know what okay okay
ha is that a lot higher than a thousand
I am so out of breath but I feel like I
could probably get it oh wait wait
okay okay you shouldn't hit it with your
toes what if I just go like this okay
okay okay okay okay maybe I need to
relax
nope go up up yeah that was four but I
need help
I'm gonna go glue this hold the ball
straight out in front of you so that it
is at the height of your test I did not
do that I just threw that in low drop it
and let it bounce as it begins to
descend
after this bounce kick it back into the
air okay so I gotta kick it back up so I
could go up to my test again try to kick
the ball with your foot angle slightly
upward make sure to kick the ball with
your laces I did say no toes keep your
ankle lock so that it stays angle and
strong a wobbly ankle leads to a wobbly
kick try to keep the ball on the control
focus on juggling on one foot until you
feel confident so do one and then after
that if you could do one well try to do
two then try to do three all right I'm
gonna try this biggest takeaway keep it
simple and try it once at a time to have
it come back up to your Chester stomach
try to catch it each time and then try
to increase the number and a tie my
shoelaces
okay okay I'm increase it to two wait
wait nope this pissing me off
okay we got to get control of the two
first yeah
oh just my toes ain't gonna lie try the
other foot it's even worse they say it's
mind over matter booth alright y'all go
to this tent go in this tent better be
calm hit it too hard hit it too hard
come on mind-body connection come on
ball
I apologize because I yelled at you do
this together you can do this then teach
me you basically got what you know what
you learned down you know you keep out
you got to keep your foot kind of angle
towards you I'm afraid of the hit in my
toes you want to hit like the meat right
here you're hitting here it's gonna go
that somewhere else it's the most
important thing is
if they hit it like that it's like
almost dancing with someone try to keep
your composure try to keep your balance
you know do you never want to dance yeah
foot and move with the ball move to the
ball take that you keep your balance you
know it's it's hard like be on your toes
[Music]
are you thinking about afterwards where
the ball is gonna go no are you thinking
that I like improv improvisation when
you're doing improv you just got to be
in the zone this is your improvisation
partner you don't know what they're
gonna see you go with the flow yeah so I
got a little toe injury so I'm gonna try
with my left foot this time but what he
was saying is let the football fall down
and let it meet your foot okay okay
timing is key
don't panic this is really hard this is
extremely hard
oh five is the goal five is the goal
one two three
I am so close come back to me now it's
4:00
ah oh you can't use your hand who came
up with these rules never give up what
about this shorter bumps not so hard
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
out of here I got five Chinese competing
20 no I don't remember that was five
five I remember earlier replayed I said
five huh you guys came here to see me do
20 so we're gonna edit it so you could
see me do 20
I'm a brush that dust off my shoulder
you saw that easy day